pressure from Congress appears to be
spurring the pharmaceutical industry to
lower prescription drug prices for some
patients one of the main producers of
insulin Sanofi said yesterday it will
cap the cost of the life-saving drug for
diabetics some could save thousands of
dollars a year the move came as
lawmakers pressed pharmaceutical
executives about the skyrocketing price
of insulin Anna Werner shows us the
fight to curb costs and a good morning I
know you've been on this story for
months we've talked about it it's a real
issue
yeah we've been hearing from patients
for a long time now who really cannot
afford this insulin and they need it to
live it's a desperate situation for many
of them well now Santa Fe says it will
sell monthly supplies of insulin for a
fixed price of $99 for some patients
that moved the latest from a drug maker
to try and cool the intensifying anger
over high prescription drug prices but
one diabetic we spoke with says there's
still much more that can be done I
cannot live without this drug can I live
without it Rob how is one of more than 7
million Americans who depend on insulin
to keep their blood sugar at safe levels
the 30 year old says he spends close to
600 dollars on monthly doses and
supplies after insurance if I didn't
have insurance it would be closer to
2,500 $3,000 a month
two years ago how made a career change
he knew would leave him without
insurance
so we stockpiled nearly six months worth
of insulin to protect himself I almost
didn't make it a guardian angel reached
out a person I didn't know and gave me
about a month's worth of insulin to
bridge the gap and really save me when I
needed it most
congressional lawmakers from both
parties grilled pharmaceutical
executives including those from top
insulin makers if you think you can you
know just out talk us without any
transparency without any accountability
I just want you to know your days are
numbered one recent study says the cost
of insulin in the US has nearly doubled
in over five years from about 2,800
dollars annually in 2012 to roughly
fifty-seven hundred dollars in 2016
prices have gotten so high
another study says one in four people
with diabetes admitted to using less
insulin than prescribed the executives
agreed patients should not have to
struggle to afford medication but blamed
rising prices on a broken health care
system current system is not working we
agree 100% that is the heart of the
issue
how says the system needs to be fixed to
make insulin affordable for everyone
diabetes is a big deal it's either by
insulin and pay what these drug
companies and pharma companies are are
charging or die like Santa Fe companies
including Express Scripts and Eli Lilly
say they've also taken steps to address
insulin prices but the head of one
patient advocacy group is skeptical of
those measures calling them just a
band-aid on a gushing wound anybody
close to a solution everybody agrees
there's a problem seems like there was a
lot of smart people who could figure it
out they need a comprehensive solution
because what many of the advocates and
experts are saying and so far that's not
in existence apparently yes if it's
coming from Washington Alexander once
said we don't do comprehensive well